Since 2001, I have been working
on what we would now call
the problem of aligning artificial
general intelligence:
how to shape the preferences and behavior
of a powerful artificial mind
such that it does not kill everyone.
I more or less founded the field
two decades ago,
when nobody else considered it
rewarding enough to work on.
I tried to get this very important
project started early
so we'd be in less
of a drastic rush later.
I consider myself to have failed.
(Laughter)
Nobody understands how modern
AI systems do what they do.
They are giant, inscrutable matrices
of floating point numbers
that we nudge in the direction
of better performance
until they inexplicably start working.
At some point, the companies
rushing headlong to scale AI
will cough out something
that's smarter than humanity.
Nobody knows how to calculate
when that will happen.
My wild guess is that it will happen
after zero to two more breakthroughs
the size of transformers.
What happens if we build
something smarter than us
that we understand that poorly?
Some people find it obvious
that building something smarter than us
that we don't understand might go badly.
Others come in with a very wide range
of hopeful thoughts
about how it might possibly go well.
Even if I had 20 minutes for this talk
and months to prepare it,
I would not be able to refute
all the ways people find to imagine
that things might go well.
But I will say that there is no
standard scientific consensus
for how things will go well.
There is no hope
that has been widely persuasive
and stood up to skeptical examination.
There is nothing resembling a real
engineering plan for us surviving
that I could critique.
This is not a good place
in which to find ourselves.
If I had more time,
I'd try to tell you
about the predictable reasons
why the current paradigm will not work
to build a superintelligence
that likes you
or is friends with you,
or that just follows orders.
Why, if you press "thumbs up"
when humans think that things went right
or "thumbs down" when another AI system
thinks that they went wrong,
you do not get a mind
that wants nice things
in a way that generalizes well
outside the training distribution
to where the AI is smarter
than the trainers.
You can search for "Yudkowsky
list of lethalities" for more.
(Laughter)
But to worry, you do not
need to believe me
about exact predictions
of exact disasters.
You just need to expect that things
are not going to work great
on the first really serious,
really critical try
because an AI system
smart enough to be truly dangerous
was meaningfully different
from AI systems stupider than that.
My prediction is that this ends up with us
facing down something smarter than us
that does not want what we want,
that does not want anything we recognize
as valuable or meaningful.
I cannot predict exactly how a conflict
between humanity and a smarter AI would go
for the same reason I can't predict
exactly how you would lose a chess game
to one of the current top
AI chess programs, let's say Stockfish.
If I could predict exactly
where Stockfish could move,
I could play chess that well myself.
I can't predict exactly
how you'll lose to Stockfish,
but I can predict who wins the game.
I do not expect something actually smart
to attack us with marching robot armies
with glowing red eyes
where there could be a fun movie
about us fighting them.
I expect an actually smarter
and uncaring entity
will figure out strategies
and technologies
that can kill us quickly
and reliably and then kill us.
I am not saying that the problem
of aligning superintelligence
is unsolvable in principle.
I expect we could figure it out
with unlimited time and unlimited retries,
which the usual process of science
assumes that we have.
The problem here is the part
where we don't get to say,
“Ha ha, whoops, that sure didn’t work.
That clever idea that used to work
on earlier systems
sure broke down when the AI
got smarter, smarter than us.”
We do not get to learn
from our mistakes and try again
because everyone is already dead.
It is a large ask
to get an unprecedented scientific
and engineering challenge
correct on the first critical try.
Humanity is not approaching
this issue with remotely
the level of seriousness
that would be required.
Some of the people leading these efforts
have spent the last decade not denying
that creating a superintelligence
might kill everyone,
but joking about it.
We are very far behind.
This is not a gap
we can overcome in six months,
given a six-month moratorium.
If we actually try
to do this in real life,
we are all going to die.
People say to me at this point,
what's your ask?
I do not have any realistic plan,
which is why I spent the last two decades
trying and failing to end up
anywhere but here.
My best bad take is that we need
an international coalition
banning large AI training runs,
including extreme
and extraordinary measures
to have that ban be actually
and universally effective,
like tracking all GPU sales,
monitoring all the data centers,
being willing to risk
a shooting conflict between nations
in order to destroy
an unmonitored data center
in a non-signatory country.
I say this, not expecting
that to actually happen.
I say this expecting that we all just die.
But it is not my place
to just decide on my own
that humanity will choose to die,
to the point of not bothering
to warn anyone.
I have heard that people
outside the tech industry
are getting this point
faster than people inside it.
Maybe humanity wakes up one morning
and decides to live.
Thank you for coming to my brief TED talk.
(Laughter)
(Applause and cheers)
Chris Anderson: So, Eliezer, thank you
for coming and giving that.
It seems like what you're raising
the alarm about is that like,
for this to happen, for an AI
to basically destroy humanity,
it has to break out, escape controls
of the internet and, you know,
start commanding actual
real-world resources.
You say you can't predict
how that will happen,
but just paint one or two possibilities.
Eliezer Yudkowsky:
OK, so why is this hard?
First, because you can't predict exactly
where a smarter chess program will move.
Maybe even more importantly than that,
imagine sending the design
for an air conditioner
back to the 11th century.
Even if they -- if it’s enough
detail for them to build it,
they will be surprised
when cold air comes out
because the air conditioner will use
the temperature-pressure relation
and they don't know
about that law of nature.
So if you want me to sketch
what a superintelligence might do,
I can go deeper and deeper into places
where we think there are predictable
technological advancements
that we haven't figured out yet.
And as I go deeper, it will get
harder and harder to follow.
It could be super persuasive.
That's relatively easy to understand.
We do not understand exactly
how the brain works,
so it's a great place to exploit
laws of nature that we do not know about.
Rules of the environment,
invent new technologies beyond that.
Can you build a synthetic virus
that gives humans a cold
and then a bit of neurological change
and they're easier to persuade?
Can you build your own synthetic biology,
synthetic cyborgs?
Can you blow straight past that
to covalently bonded
equivalents of biology,
where instead of proteins that fold up
and are held together by static cling,
you've got things that go down
much sharper potential energy gradients
and are bonded together?
People have done advanced design work
about this sort of thing
for artificial red blood cells
that could hold 100 times as much oxygen
if they were using tiny
sapphire vessels to store the oxygen.
There's lots and lots
of room above biology,
but it gets harder and harder
to understand.
CA: So what I hear you saying
is that these terrifying
possibilities there
but your real guess is that AIs will work
out something more devious than that.
Is that really a likely
pathway in your mind?
EY: Which part?
That they're smarter
than I am? Absolutely.
CA: Not that they're smarter,
but why would they want
to go in that direction?
Like, AIs don't have our feelings of
sort of envy and jealousy and anger
and so forth.
So why might they go in that direction?
EY: Because it's convergently implied
by almost any of the strange,
inscrutable things that they
might end up wanting
as a result of gradient descent
on these "thumbs up"
and "thumbs down" things internally.
If all you want is to make tiny
little molecular squiggles
or that's like, one component
of what you want,
but it's a component that never saturates,
you just want more and more of it,
the same way that we would want
more and more galaxies filled with life
and people living happily ever after.
Anything that just keeps going,
you just want to use more
and more material for that,
that could kill everyone
on Earth as a side effect.
It could kill us because it doesn't want
us making other superintelligences
to compete with it.
It could kill us because it's using up
all the chemical energy on earth
and we contain some
chemical potential energy.
CA: So some people in the AI world worry
that your views are strong enough
and they would say extreme enough
that you're willing to advocate
extreme responses to it.
And therefore, they worry
that you could be, you know,
in one sense, a very destructive figure.
Do you draw the line yourself
in terms of the measures
that we should take
to stop this happening?
Or is actually anything
justifiable to stop
the scenarios you're talking
about happening?
EY: I don't think that "anything" works.
I think that this takes state actors
and international agreements
and all international agreements
by their nature,
tend to ultimately be backed by force
on the signatory countries
and on the non-signatory countries,
which is a more extreme measure.
I have not proposed that individuals
run out and use violence,
and I think that the killer argument
for that is that it would not work.
CA: Well, you are definitely not
the only person to propose
that what we need is some kind
of international reckoning here
on how to manage this going forward.
Thank you so much
for coming here to TED, Eliezer.
(Applause)